Hey youtubers it's Charlie and some new details
about the characters in episode 7 have been
revealed just like those leaked pictures from
the tatooine set. They're mostly about the
main character that's going to be the new
Luke Skywalker. Not the actual character,
the person that the film is going to introduce
us to the new Star Wars Universe. There's
also some big updates on classic characters
that are coming back. So I'm going to do a
full breakdown of everything.
If you're finding me for the first time I'm
doing star wars bonus videos until Rebels
gets here in the fall, be sure to subscribe
to get everything. And feel free to leave
me suggestions for bonus topics.
So the most important stuff. John Boyega's
character is supposed to be the person the
story uses to introduce us to the new JJ Abrams
Disney Star Wars Universe. He's getting the
Luke Skywalker character arc or something
similar.
What does this mean? Well remember how in
Episode 4 Luke was living in the middle of
nowhere had no idea he was special, and only
had a passing knowledge of the Empire and
the Galactic Civil War. He was completely
regular but had big dreams. That's what John
Boyega's character is supposed to be like.
He was part of that group of people filming
the early scenes on the Tatooine sets, so
at the very least it confirms a few things.
The rumors are that it's his character development
will be very similar to Luke Skywalkers, so
he's not going to be a Jedi or even a padawan
at the beginning. But he'll slowly develop
as the sequels come.
As for the actual Jedi, we know Mark Hamill
is back as Luke Skywalker. He's been getting
back in shape and growing his Obi Wan Kenobi
Jedi beard. So clearly he's going to be the
spiritual leader of the new franchise.
Because of all the Tatooine Luke Skywalker
repeats with John Boyega I'm wondering if
Luke himself will follow a modified version
of Obi-Wan's character arc in the original
trilogy. You see what's happening. They're
honoring the classic films with the real life
props and using the same film camera and they're
kind of lightly using the same story beats
at first.
I don't expect them to just cut and paste
the plot. But a really safe way to appease
the superfans would be to do the Battlestar
Galactica thing where all the characters realize
all these things have happened before and
they will happen again.
If you're not familiar with the plot of Ronald
D. Moore's Battlestar feel free to ask for
clarification on that metaphor.
More characters though. I have seen the rumors
about Lupita maybe being Obi Wan Kenobi's
grand daughter. I think that would be fine
but it would be a departure from the movie
canon. There was no point in any of George
Lucas' films that Obi-Wan had any kind of
romance with anyone. So I'd be really curious
as to where a grand daughter would come from.
But if JJ Abrams time travel rebooted Star
Trek, I wouldn't be surprised if he retconned
some things from the Original Trilogy. Prepare
yourself for that to happen.
The primary antagonist initially is supposed
to be a female Sith character. The best theories
I've seen since last week are that it will
be Gwendoline Christie. It's going to be female
and a main cast member, and how many women
have they cast in the movie so far? Practically
none aside from Leia. And no, it's not going
to be her. Wouldn't that be crazy?
I just keep remembering this interview Gwendoline
Christie did at the beginning of Game of Thrones
Season 4 where she said she had to bite someone's
ear off in a scene and kind of laughed at
how ridiculous and violent it was. I'm wondering
if the Star Wars people saw that scene and
said "hey she would make an excellent sith
warrior".
Something Clone Wars did with Asajj Ventress,
but someone that's a closer analog to Darth
Vader. Gwendoline Christie looks about the
same size as David Prowse, the actor who wore
the Darth Vader costume. So it's possible.
I don't think they'd make her wear a mask
though.
Speaking of villains, remember how the original
trilogy developed? Darth Vader was the antagonist
of the first film and most of the second.
But then they introduced the Emperor. Well,
don't be surprised if we don't find out who
the Sith Master is until the second film.
But just looking at the casting sheet my eyes
dart to Max Von Sydow, just because he looks
like a villain. But that's kind of an obvious
move. So feel free to suggest another possibility.
They will cast more new people when we get
to the second film. So we might not even see
the Sith Master's face till then.
The only other new things we've learned about
the movie is that despite it being like 30
years after Return of the Jedi, there will
be no New Republic. That doesn't mean the
Empire is still going strong, but the New
Republic was something that evolved in the
expanded universe, so I'm not surprised they
aren't using it.
The last thing is spinoff related. Supposedly
Boba Fett Armor or Mandalorian armor however
you want to think about it, was spotted on
the set. No confirmation on what role he'll
play in the first film. But it's likely that
he'll just be teased and they'll use a post
credits scene with him to tease the first
spinoff.
Disney hasn't confirmed which spinoff is coming
first and they probably won't until Episode
7 comes just to maintain the surprise of that
post-credits scene. But because Disney owns
both Marvel and Star Wars now, expect them
to do the Marvel Universe thing where each
film teases the next one.
Let me know in the comments what you think
about Brienne being like the new big huge
Darth Vader sith warrior and if they do make
Lupita Obi-Wan's grand daughter, will you
be upset that they're changing the story of
the original trilogy?
I think I could live with it. It's happened
to so many other franchises, that if it helps
the story in any way, I feel it will be an
improvement from the prequels. I'm not a prequel
hater or anything, but JJ Abrams has already
fired Michael Arndt, the person who wrote
the first draft of the Episode 7 script. And
he wasn't a bad writer, he was the guy who
wrote Toy Story 3, which was really good..
Since we're starting to learn a lot more about
episode 7 my next bonus video will either
be plot related or a bonus video about my
favorite expanded universe stories. Be sure
to subscribe to get it.
Oh, almost forgot. Billy Dee Williams will
be playing Lando Calrissian in the Star Wars
Rebels cartoon this fall. He didn't say how
big his part is or how many episodes he's
in. But I'm guessing he'll just be a recurring
guest star.
Right now click here to learn more about episode
7 and click here to learn more about Avengers
2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!